[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
you see how
you know i was holding him
see how this arm we we had a close
relationship he was
my wife's first child emotional
testimony as dante wright's father takes
the stand in minnesota versus kim potter
plus a return to new york as the defense
begins its case in geelane maxwell's sex
trafficking trial and closing arguments
begin in the trial for former therino
ceo and founder elizabeth holmes when
the case could be handed to the jury
plus convicted sex offender harvey
weinstein back in the spotlight could
one of his convictions be thrown out
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we're starting off in minnesota
where the state rests its case in the
trial of ex-cop kim potter potter is
accused of shooting and killing dante
wright during a traffic stop earlier
this year the prosecution began its case
with emotional testimony from wright's
girlfriend and his mother the state
closed its case with another emotional
witness wright's father aubry wright
wright told jurors about his close
relationship with his son and the
tight-knit family get-togethers movie
nights and cookouts they hosted he
served as a spark of life witness
testifying about his experience seeing
his son become a father
man to see him as a father
it was like i was so happy for him
because he was so happy
he was so happy about junior
and this was my chance to be a
grandfather
did they have a close relationship
yes
and dante junior spent a lot of time
with your family as well
yeah dante junior
you know dante lived with us
dream was pretty much there
every day
and he loved he loved his son
and you love your son dante a lot as
well
a lot
i love dante he was loved
do you miss him i miss him a lot every
day
potter faces first and second degree
manslaughter charges stemming from the
shooting death of dante wright in
brooklyn center minnesota in april
officers say wright was pulled over for
an expired tag wright told his mother he
was being pulled over for an air
freshener hanging from his rearview
mirror body cam footage shows officers
attempting to arrest wright after they
determined he had a warrant out for his
arrest amid a struggle wright gets back
into his car as potter shoots him in the
chest he died as a result of those
injuries as his car sped away and hit
another car potter maintains she
accidentally pulled her handgun instead
of her taser there's been debate over
whether her use of force was justified
on thursday the defense called its first
witness another expert on use of force
steven ims attorneys asked him about
potter's use of her firearm and whether
her fellow officer could have been
injured in the traffic stop as they
argue he was a was halfway in wright's
car on the passenger side just before
the car sped off
the question sir would be answered first
by just understanding the basic
uh decision making process involving
deadly force and that is can i
reasonably articulate
a belief that myself or another is in
immediate danger of risk of death or
great bodily harm
so if that's the standard
as an officer assessing the
appropriateness of deadly force
an officer half in and half out of a
vehicle
that is about to be put into drive with
the door open would certainly meet that
standard of being in immediate danger of
death or serious physical injury
so an officer saying that could shoot it
would meet that standard and an officer
could shoot yes sir
through the kim potter and trial the
shadow of derrick chauvin's case has
always been close by wright was shot and
killed just outside of minneapolis as
shoving was on trial for the death of
george floyd a connecting link between
the cases is courtney ross the fiancee
of george floyd and the one-time teacher
of dante wright law and crime networks
spoke with ross and several peaceful
protesters outside the hennepin county
courthouse this week
i don't think anyone wants to be in the
limelight for losing someone that's not
it's a horrible feeling
i will say though that
i've been i was saying earlier like it's
my lifestyle now this is my this is my
role through god now so
it's my job now to fight for other
families that don't get the attention
that point guard and there's so
many i mean i i i even fret today like
every day with dante's face i pray that
it gets more light i pray that more
people are interested because the more
attention the more pressure
and
then we will see a guilty verdict
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie renderman and terry
austin julia defends his use of force
expert seems strong on direct but on
cross we learned he didn't view or
recall all of the evidence how's that
going to play out
so look anytime you have a witness
testifying for either side you have to
wait for the cross-examination because
you have to kind of as a jury look at
the direct and the cross to see how they
do on both ends i will say i think
either way he did a very good job look i
i was a brooklyn homicide prosecutor we
saw cases where individual officers who
did stops were pulled i i know a
specific one where they were pulled and
almost killed and were permanently brain
damaged so that there's something there
that the defense has to work with and
the issue is whether or not the jurors
are going to buy those two-ish those
those two things they're selling um in
terms of a the reasonableness of what
she did and b whether or not she would
have had the right to use an actual
loaded gun at that time obviously it's
up to the jury but i i think this
witness did it did a pretty good job
even with the issues regarding the
prosecution cross-examination now terry
there were many officers some that
worked with and above
kim potter how did they testify during
the defenses case
the defense is trying to show two things
with these officers first of all that
kim potter was law abiding and peaceful
and also that she used reasonable force
like julie said the expert testified
that what she used as far as that taser
was concerned was reasonable but as far
as the peaceful and abiding i thought
the officers who got on the stand were a
little weak they were limited because
the judge limited them to those issues
but you know it's up to the jury to
decide whether or not that really makes
a difference to them i would say how
this case continues as more testimony
rolls in the case of minnesota versus
kim potter still ahead on law and crime
daily the final chapter in the
months-long fraud trial for former ceo
elizabeth holmes as the jury hears
closing arguments but first defense
attorneys for british socialite elaine
maxwell called their first witness in
the federal sex trafficking trial in new
york all that and more still ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defense begins its case in new york as
elaine maxwell's federal sex trafficking
trial started back up on thursday
the 59-year-old british socialite is
charged with six felonies including
conspiracy to entice minors to engage in
illegal sex acts and transportation of a
minor to engage in an illegal sex act
the charges stem from her relationship
with former financer jeffrey epstein
epstein was charged with similar crimes
in 2019 before he was found dead by
suicide in his jail cell federal
prosecutors say maxwell and epstein
groomed girls as young as 14 years old
for sexual abuse the prosecution rested
his case friday after 10 days and 24
witnesses testified four of them were
women who say they were sexually abused
by epstein when they were underage and
then maxwell enabled it to happen and
sometimes participated herself maxwell's
defense is arguing she's a scapegoat for
epstein's actions
law and crime network's adam classfield
has been following this case from the
beginning and was inside the courtroom
as the defense called its first witness
he joins us now with the latest out of
new york
we are here in front of the thurgood
marshall courthouse for the opening day
of glenn maxwell's defense case they
started off with a witness that we long
anticipated would take the stand
elizabeth luftus who is a defense expert
who testifies on the science of what she
calls false memories now remember glenn
maxwell's defense team is going to try
to
answer the testimony of three compelling
government witnesses and fourth witness
who essentially accused glenn maxwell of
facilitating jeffrey epstein's sexual
abuse and in some cases participating in
the abuse from the ages of 14 to 17
years old she is a something of a
celebrity witness she has either
consulted with or testified in the cases
of bill cosby harvey weinstein oj
simpson and many others as a matter of
fact on the witness stand today she said
that she testified in more than 300
cases only five or six of those were
consulting with the prosecution and only
once has she testified for the
prosecution this is adam klasfeld
reporting for the law and crime network
thanks adam let's bring back criminal
defense attorney julie reynolds and
terry austin to break down the newest
twists in the maxwell trial
terry what is the argument being
developed by the defense witness and is
it spelling not guilty
i don't think so there are only a couple
of things they're trying to say they're
saying that she's a scapegoat as we've
discussed and that because you can't get
to epstein they're trying to get to her
and they are also trying to force the
jury to think that these you know
accusers are lying and you know those
two things could very well backfire on
them there were some inconsistencies
with jane the prosecution was trying to
say she initially told fbi she didn't
know the first time maxwell and epstein
were together
and she admitted now she knew when that
occurred and it could very well look
like to the jury
that the prosecution is blaming the
victim here so i think saying things
like are you crying on command to jane
is not going to help either so i don't
think their arguments so far are working
but at the end of the day i think the
jury might just try to use maxwell
now julie the defense did something very
interesting it's unique and at least as
far as i know unprecedented to ask that
the witnesses for the defense remain
anonymous similar to that of the
prosecution now that was denied by the
judge but your thoughts on the request
and the denial
well it's funny you said unprecedented
because the judge agreed with you um
because it was unprecedented and that's
why the judge ruled against them look
it's one thing for the prosecution to
ask for
alleged victims of sex crimes to have
their names not out there to protect
them there is case law that supports
that there is no case law that supports
the idea that every witness no matter
who they are can come in anonymously
simply because they don't want their
names out there they didn't raise any
actual
valid issues in terms of safety or
anything like as you would with
potentially an undercover officer for
example and because they didn't they
really had no basis to do it the judge
denied it and it wasn't a shock yeah
interesting argument but didn't really
seem to have a leg to stand on and like
it happens from time to time a judge
does agree with me so thank you for that
julie uh moving down to texas where the
trial for ex-police officer aaron dean
is being delayed his defense team says
two witnesses had scheduling conflicts
with the results of the trial which was
set to start in january the former fort
worth cop is accused in the 2019
shooting death of a black woman in
october 2019 dean responded to a welfare
call out of tatiana jefferson's mother's
house jefferson heard dean and another
officer walking through her backyard
when she grabbed a gun from her purse
dean fired the shop through a window
which hit jefferson she died as a result
of her injuries at the time of the
shooting jefferson was babysitting her
nephew if convicted dean could face a
sentence of life in prison aaron dean's
attorneys are also pushing for the trial
to be moved out of tarrant county saying
the extensive news coverage will make it
impossible to have a fair trial jury
selection will now begin may 9th with a
trial to start a week later
another trial delayed in los angeles
where the trial of a man accused of
gunning down a well-known rapper in 2019
is postponed yet again
it's been more than two and a half years
since eric holder allegedly shot and
killed the rapper known as nipsy hustle
outside his la clothing store holder's
trial was fa has faced several delays so
far starting with a coven 19 pandemic
holder's former attorney also resigned
after receiving harassing messages and
threats on top of that a previous judge
retired before holder's case could go to
trial the latest delay comes from the
state as the prosecutor in the case had
surgery and is still recovering the
trial is set for this coming january but
on wednesday it was postponed to begin
in march the trial could possibly now
overlap with the three-year anniversary
of the shooting
coming up on law and crime daily closing
arguments begin after months of
testimony in the fraud trial of
theranow's founder elizabeth holmes
plus could a convicted sex offender's
rape conviction be thrown out details on
the appeal from former film mogul harvey
weinstein
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
closing arguments begin in the federal
trial of elizabeth holmes the
prosecution began with his closing
arguments thursday morning saying
elizabeth holmes can be the had the
chance to be honest but she chose
instead to defraud investors prosecutors
said quote that choice was not only
callous it was criminal prosecutors
argued that holmes text messages and
emails show that she had knowledge about
theranos's shortcomings and had intent
to commit fraud the defense is expected
to follow with closing arguments then
the prosecution will have a second
closing before the case is handed over
to the jury
which could possibly happen as soon as
friday holmes is the founder and former
ceo of theranos a silicon valley lab
touted as being a breakthrough blood
testing company she's accused of lying
about the technology to investors to get
more funding she once claimed the now
defunct company theranos would
revolutionize blood testing but later
tests found many issues with the
technology holmes is charged with two
counts of conspiracy to commit wire
fraud and nine counts of wire fraud if
convicted she could face 20 years in
prison plus restitution
back to break down closing arguments as
criminal defense attorney julie renlman
and co-host terry austin terry what
major takeaways do you think the jury
took from the prosecution's closing
i think they're probably trying to
determine whether or not this was just
exaggeration and puffery or whether or
not this really was fraud the
prosecution is clearly trying to make it
seem more than just over-promising and
under-delivering they're trying to make
it seem as though she intentionally
misled investors and clients and
partners they're explaining and they
will talk more about this that she
intentionally misled investors and she
you know knew the machines weren't
working and she used machines from other
companies i think the jury is going to
think about all that and wonder whether
or not she did this intentionally or she
was just trying to promote her company
like lots of people do in silicon valley
all right now julie on the other side
how was the defense going to respond and
raise any kind of reasonable doubt to
try to win this case
it look their their defense basically
even though they called several
witnesses really relied on her she
testified it what was it seven or eight
days under cross examination
and at the end of the day she gave a
complicated a bit confusing a bit
inconsistent
level of testimony that in many ways
blamed her boyfriend at the time for his
uh for domestic violence towards her
that caused these all these things to
happen i think that's going to be a
problem i think the jury's not buying
that and i think the best thing they
have is what terry kind of talked about
is the idea is did she intentionally
defraud investors or did she use puffery
i mean that is kind of the the thing
that the jury's gonna have to decide and
i think if they push towards the
domestic violence the jury's not going
to buy any of it all right we'll see how
it plays out again we've just got more
closing arguments both for the defense
and prosecution and we'll give you
updates as we continue when we come back
a disgraced hollywood filmmaker's
lawyers work to get a sexual assault
conviction overturned the arguments
harvey weinstein's attorney is making to
appeal
welcome back to long crime daily
disgrace movie producer harvey weinstein
could have his conviction on sex crimes
charges in new york thrown out at a
hearing this week appeals court judges
question what they called prejudicial
evidence used to convict weinstein the
judge in the new york case allowed three
women to testify for the prosecution
about their claims that weinstein
assaulted them however weinstein was not
charged with assaulting those women law
and crime spoke with weinstein's
attorney in the new york case about the
conviction last summer
these are all women of
adult age all women who at least in my
case in new york and some of the l.a
witnesses who testified as other crimes
witnesses in new york all testified to
the fact that they wanted something from
harvey weinstein and so you know the
question becomes can we put all these
cases in the same box and i really don't
think that we can i will maintain um
until the end of my career or maybe
until my grave that they did not have
enough evidence to find harvey guilty in
that case and they did find him not
guilty of free of account so i mean
that's something that to think
about weinstein is in jail in los
angeles awaiting trial a judge refused
to dismiss his case last week
and one of the first of harvey
weinstein's accusers actress rose
mcgowan won't have her lawsuit case
against him heard in court which is
separate from the sexual assault
allegations this comes after was
dismissed by a california judge last
week the lawsuit accused weinstein and
his attorneys of trying to silence her
from coming forward with rape
allegations the judge says mccowan
missed the deadline to file paperwork in
her case her claims were dismissed with
prejudice meaning she can't refile the
same claim again in that court
julie the main issue in this appeals
case seems to be prejudicial evidence
what exactly is that and where's the
line for prosecutions when presenting
that in a case
look we saw this in bill cosby although
they overturned for different reasons i
mean the issue is whether or not the
judge allowed extrinsic evidence into
this case to such a degree that the
prejudicial value of that evidence
outweighed the probative meaning did the
jury basically find him guilty because
he's just a really bad guy based on this
extrinsic evidence or because he
actually committed the crimes of which
he's charged um and that's an answer i i
i you know obviously i can't you know
speak to um and so that's a question
obviously that that the appellate
division is is deciding um and so i
think that it looks like there's a
problem for the prosecution because the
prosecution doesn't have an answer to
the questions when they say this is why
don't you agree this is overkill um and
so that's that that's the problem at
this point yeah now terry i know it's
reading tea leaves but that's what we do
here based on the justice's response
where do you think this appeal is
heading
well you know what i think is very
interesting it's an all-female bench on
this court of appeals and it's hard to
say what they're going to ultimately
decide but based on their comments it
does seem as though they are leaning to
overturning the decision and that you
know the argument the prosecution was
trying to make and one of the judges
said it rubbed her the wrong way so i
think there is a distinct possibility
that we could see something like that
they certainly didn't agree that
character should have come in julie's
right they thought that that was too
much and that it was not probative and
it was more prejudicial than anything
else but i do think that if in fact it's
overturned we're going to have a lot of
outcry because this is again going to be
the second time that this is happening
and it's definitely going to be a
setback as far as the metoo movement is
concerned when you have two big
individuals like bill cosby and harvey
weinstein and their judgments are you
know overturned so we'll see what
happens yeah definitely effect
prosecution is going forward as well
well thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you